[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance it now seems evident that if
Donald Trump were to ask his new FBI
director Christopher Rea why he has yet
to tell America that Trump has been
cleared of any wrongdoing
regarding the Russia scandal director
Ray would be forced to tell Trump that
this is because Trump has not been
cleared of any wrongdoing regarding the
Russia scandal and that in fact Trump
and his circle are being investigated in
nothing less than nine separate Russian
scandals the New York Times has reported
that Special Counsel Robert Muller has
requested documents from the White House
relating to the actions of Trump and
others in 13 different areas the
newspaper was vague about these areas
but it identified at least 10 of them
the FBI interview of Michael Flynn about
the kiss lyac phone calls the White
House response to the Justice Department
concerns that Flynn could be blackmailed
the firing of Flynn the firing of James
Comey Trump's meetings with Comey shown
Spicer's statement in May that Trump had
full confidence in Comey
Trump's meeting in the Oval Office with
the Russian Foreign Minister and kiss
react which touched on Comey the first
statement from Donald Trump jr. about
the so called adoption meeting
everything about Paul Manafort and
everything about six members of trumps
campaign foreign policy team including
Carter Paige and JD Gordon that's a lot
of areas and adding them to what else we
think we know it does not take a lawyer
to sort these out into specific scandal
categories any one of which could take
down Trump's presidency by itself there
isn't one
Trump Russia scandal there are at least
nine of them ranking them by comparative
heat and by new information from last to
first scandal number nine the Trump
Putin private meeting forgot about that
one didn't you at the g20 meeting in
Hamburg in July there does not seem to
be anything new about this and it seems
hard to conceive how Muller gets
anything about it anyway given that it
was just Trump Putin and Putin's
translator that's kind of the point but
this is just a reminder that if you need
ugly guilty-looking optics this is where
to start
of course it's just possible the Germans
the whole place bugged where the
Russians did or we did scandal number
eight firing Michael Flynn well this one
is the whole circus around general Flynn
and his speaking engagement for Russian
owned TV at his work for Turkey that his
phone calls to the Russian ambassador
during the transition and the Justice
Department fear that the Russians could
have been blackmailing him it is a mess
it has prongs to Russia to come jr. to
manna fort two Kushner to trump himself
and in what's new here to Flynn's son
Michael G Flynn who NBC News says is now
a subject of the investigation into the
election and collusion in part because
of his work with his father's lobbying
firm scandal number seven hacking the
DNC computer as time goes by it just
gets stranger the trunk called on the
Russians to find Hillary Clinton's
emails on July 27th 2016 then 14 days
later Trump's old buddy Roger stone said
he had been in contact with Julian
Assange then the eleven days after that
stone tweeted it would soon be John
Podesta time in the barrel and then 47
days after that WikiLeaks began to
release Podesta's emails one hour after
the Billy Bush Access Hollywood tape was
revealed what's new here is the
California congressman Dana Rohrabacher
and his bizarre attempt to get Trump to
pardon Julian Assange scandal number six
oh yeah
altering the outcome of the election the
whole point the possibility that who won
and who lost was actually changed from
Clinton winning to Trump winning it
remains nebulous and it may never be
proved nor disproved but it is important
to remember that if anything will turn
up pertinent truth it is the
investigation of the other eight Trump
Russia scandals scandal number five
firing Comey obviously there's a trump
prong here he did it there's also a
White House cover-up prong a potential
obstruction of justice prong a paper
trail prong including evidence of
premeditation namely the first draft of
the letter allegedly reading I'm firing
you over Russia but with the Times
report there is now the suggestion that
it doesn't have a Russia prong it has
two of them Muller wants to know why
Trump fired Comey and then the neck
des allegedly told the Russian
ambassador and the Russian Foreign
Minister that Comey was a quote nut job
and that he Trump had quote faced great
pressure because of Russia that's taken
off scandal number four Jared Kushner so
now it's been reported that son-in-law
used newly established private email
addresses rather than government
addresses on which he conducted
transition business his prongs going to
the desperate finances and alleged
overtures to Russia about a building his
family owns and into a Russian banker
named Gourcuff who graduated from
Russia's intelligence training academy
and has links to Putin and into the
Russian adoption meeting and especially
into that bid to establish a secure back
channel between the Trump gang and
Russia using Russian diplomatic systems
and that now ties into the explanation
from the former national security
adviser Susan Rice that she did unmask
some American intelligence intercepts
because it turns out that one of the
people trying to help set up the secret
trump communications channel to Russia
was the crown prince of the United Arab
Emirates scandal number three the
continuing Adventures of Paul Manafort
my god where to begin now there's a
report that while in charge of Trump's
campaign he offered to give private
briefings to a Russian billionaire on
how the campaign was going and there's
the other report that the FBI started to
monitor his interactions with the then
pro-russian Ukrainian regime in 2014 and
the other other report that while this
newest scandal is breaking mana fork
might have been planning another trip
abroad and nobody seems to be stopping
him prongs Paul Manafort is made out of
nothing but prongs scandal number two
Trump juniors tower meeting this is the
adoption thing with Manafort Kushner the
Russian lawyer and the other shady
Russians this scandal has a Russian
prong sticking out of one side obviously
and as a trump campaign prong sticking
out of the other side since Trump jr.
went in there having been told he was to
meet middlemen who were going to give
him Russian government dirt on Hillary
Clinton to use in the election but more
importantly this also has a trump
prong sticking right on top of it
because at minimum as the press
secretary herself said Trump himself
quote weighed in on the statement his
son issued falsely claiming that this
was just a meeting about adoptions that
means it also has a White House cover-up
prong sticking out of it too and Muller
now wants all the White House documents
and scandal number one Facebook and
Russia's $100,000 worth of targeted
election advertising this recently shot
up the rankings after somebody found
this quote from last December and former
Facebook ad salesman Antonio Garcia
Martinez who said it's crazy that
Zuckerberg says there's no way Facebook
can influence the election when there's
a whole sales force in Washington DC
that does nothing but convince
advertisers that they can we used to
joke that we could sell the whole
election to the highest bidder the
Facebook scandal has Russian prong and
it has a Jared Kushner prong since he
boasted of using targeted Facebook ads
for his father-in-law's campaign and
since Kushner brought in Cambridge
analytic and as a prong for that
company's financier the billionaire
Trump fan Robert Mercer and the man who
owned at least five million dollars
worth of principle in it
Steve Bannon and now there's a second
Steve Bannon prong with BuzzFeed
reporting an email chain showing that
just before he joined Trump's campaign
Bannon sought to put a mole inside
Facebook who would report back to him
and of course it has at its core the
hacking prong the campaign's data
operation which the Trump team thought
swung the election may have relied upon
Facebook ads that were targeted to
voters using information that may have
been stolen by the Russians from
government computers in this country
last week 21 US states were informed by
homeland security that the Russians
tried to hack into their voter
registration rolls before the election
that's nine scandals by my count nine
Trump Russia scandals you might divide
and assemble them differently you might
rank their importance differently and
yet each of our lists might be missing a
bigger Trump Russia
and yet the denial Trump's denial not
just that he did anything but that
anything even happened
our former ambassador to the Czech
Republic former Assistant Secretary of
State John Shattuck wrote this in the
Boston Globe on December 16th of last
year it is I think truer now than it was
even then by denigrating or seeking to
prevent an investigation of the Russian
cyberattack Trump is giving aid or
comfort to an enemy of the United States
that he is in fact seeking to cover up
his staffs or his own involvement in or
prior knowledge of the attack for him to
continue to deny Russia's cyberattack
and resist the investigation invites a
specter of treason to hover over the
president-elect treason doth never
prosper what's the reason so asked the
British courtier and author John
Harrington four hundred years ago
why if it prosper he answered none dare
call it treason resist remove peace